there's a smart drone nearly all of us
rely on every single day to boost our
concentration to help ourselves wake up
to improve our memories of course the
title someone giving away my plot twist
I'm mostly talking about caffeine but
what exactly does caffeine do to your
brain does it really make me smarter
let's find out
so you don't need me to tell you what
happens when you use caffeine your
anyone normal you probably had it a few
times yourself what you'll find is it
raises your heart rate slightly makes
you focus more makes you feel less tired
my gets white wire feeling I actually
massively rely on caffeine like way more
than usual that's because I am a
freelance writer so most of my days been
sitting down typing out words and I get
paid by the word so the more words I can
write in a day the more get paid it's as
fascinating for me someone is interested
in self-development brain training
transhumanism because it basically means
that as I improve myself and my
efficiency I increase my profit there's
no limit the limit is what I'm capable
of outputting so yeah caffeine is one of
the tools I use to certainly feel a lot
more work I have to buy some kind of
drinks to sit and prep in Starbucks the
cost of all day otherwise they probably
have security is caught me out but also
I drink it because it actually really
does help be a firm at work
I've been produced in a certain amount
of time if I drink a strong white
americano you know two or three times
during the day
it'll probably increase my alpha by two
thousand three thousand words maybe
you're not in exactly that book maybe
you don't get paid per output each day
however if you perform better then you
of course get noticed hopefully and
eventually that might lead to a
promotion a better salary essentially
caffeine works by reducing the action of
a neurotransmitter called adenosine in
the brain adenosine is an inhibitory
neurotransmitter what that means is that
it quietens action between brain cells
it reduces the rates of firing so you
bring quietens down Garber is another
example of an inhibitory
neurotransmitter
normally as adenosine builds up during
the day our brains quieten down and
activity is reduced this is a byproduct
of the energy processes in the brain it
comes from ATP which comes
blue case when your cells breakdown ATP
adenosine is released and this just
builds up over time and you get tighter
and more groggy when you drink the
caffeine however this blocks those
receptors in the brain cells that are
designed to receive their density and
that prevents it from working so
suddenly you're not so tired you're not
so groggy you wake back up basically
it's reversing one of the processes that
makes it feel tired as the day drags on
it reduces brain fog makes you less
sleepy makes you feel more awake of
course it can also make it more
difficult to get to sleep Cheers
I'm not sponsored by Starbucks by the
way this is just a good size of mug with
a nice pleasing thinness of China around
the edge some of the other footage has
been in pret so that's proof all say I
don't have enough views and my videos on
high quality enough but the interesting
effects of caffeine don't stop there
because once you increase the amount of
biome in your brain you have a kind of
cascading effect which changes all sorts
of things so you got more firing in the
brain that releases more glutamate
glutamate is the principal excitatory
neurotransmitter of the brain so you can
consider it almost like the opposite of
a dinner Z is associated with more
action in the brain it means your brain
becomes more lively once you have more
glutamate this results in more dopamine
dopamine is what we often consider the
reward hormone that's a little bit of an
oversimplification actually date winners
release in the anticipation of reward
increases motivation focus and memory
because we think what's happening is
important it's also associated with
feeling good so that's one of the
reasons the caffeine feels so great then
you have norepinephrine norepinephrine
is of course one of the fight-or-flight
neurotransmitters this is released when
we're highly stressed when we think
we're in in danger and it causes our
heart rate to increase it causes
palpitations trends at the same time
just to kind of
tunnel vision and focus and actually
speeds up rate of our thought and
directs blood away from things like
digestion and towards our brain so
basically that increases your brainpower
but it can also cause many of these side
effects that people don't enjoy from
Kathy such as the Apple mentioned
palpitations anxiety and difficulty
sleeping on top of this you also get an
increased release of cortisol which is
often released alongside norepinephrine
of course a stress forming and you get
an increase in serotonin because of the
increase in dopamine are those those two
you can sometimes act against one
another so you have all sorts going on
in your brain and I try and talk about
this in my previous videos you can't
affect one year transmitter without
having this cascading effect I still opt
so now the question becomes should you
use caffeine it's actually overall good
for you it does give you a brain boost
or does it make you anxious and jittery
so different people react differently to
caffeine and in terms of those side
effects associated with norepinephrine
your mileage may vary assuming you have
a kind of more normal reaction to
caffeine and you're not massively
overdosing then it has pros and cons so
on the one hand yes Nach nephron does
raise the heart rate does cause anxiety
and it can make it difficult to sleep
it's advisable that you stop drinking
caffeine before for unless you want it
to affect your sleep and this can end up
creating something of a knock-on effect
that means you lie in the next day have
more caffeine have worse sleep the next
day you see what I mean if you want to
boost your energy in your brain power
sleep is actually far more effective
than caffeine so you should prioritize
sleep over caffeine if you're going to
focus on just one another concern with
caffeine is that it can lead to
tolerance and even dependence so what
happens is as you keep blocking those
adenosine receptors your brain responds
by creating more than Zee receptors so
what this means is that now you feel
tired
until you get the caffeine increases the
base of the hole is trying to maintain a
normal equilibrium remember
everything in your brain attacking there
for a reason you need the identity to
feel quiet and tired at the end of the
day so if your brain thinks I'm not
getting enough it changes shape it
changes structure to make sure that it
will get enough you now need to drink
more caffeine in order to get the same
effect and you need to drink some
caffeine just to feel normal and there
are studies that suggest that for many
people what they think is them feeling
groggy in the morning what they think is
brain fog associated with lack of sleep
is actually caffeine withdrawal and
caffeine does actually do a lot of good
for you as well for starters it's been
shame to be near protective against
Parkinson's disease and some other
conditions so it can actually prevent
age-related decline in the brain and
other kind of deterioration it's also an
antioxidant on top of this caffeine
doesn't through focus it doesn't free
memory largely due to the day for me and
so if you're just trying to get that
boost that you need whether you're
cramming for an exam or like me writing
really long article getting paid by the
word
then it's a very useful tool caffeine
has even been credited as being
responsible for the Renaissance the idea
is that we used to drink beer because
the water was infected and that led to
us being not so smart all the time
they drank beer all day then we realized
we could drink hot drinks like team
coffee and tea houses started emerging
throughout Europe suddenly people became
a little bit smarter and more eloquent
great ideas followed on from that and
you have the Renaissance and the
Enlightenment say yeah caffeine can't be
all that bad and if you want to get more
of the positive effects without some of
the negative effects there are things
you can do to make caffeine a little bit
more gentle some people use it with
l-theanine one of the most basic
nootropic stats is to drink caffeine
without feeling together and they occur
together naturally in green tea
l-theanine is an amine acid and it does
increase focus but it also slightly
quietens down takes the edge off the
caffeine so if you want to have more
folks without the jitters that might be
one option for you you can even try
drinking a green tea such as you ever
mate which Darwin described as the
world's most perfect
stimulant so yeah caffeine has a lot of
effects on brain it does a lot of
different things to you and it's really
up to you whether you want to keep using
it I have to keep using it because I
badly addicted hope you enjoyed this
video hope you found it interesting and
useful and if so please like share and
subscribe we're trying to increase my
production value if there's always just
got a new camera
I'm trying news and you recorded
provided if that's gonna go to video yet
even got new lighting and stuff so yeah
hope you found it a little bit improved
from my previous videos and I'll be
continuing hopefully with this higher
standard of quality along with the usual
content on the brain on working from
home productivity bodybuilding you name
it so please stick around and I'll see
you in the next one thanks very much for
watching bye for now